the dark knight has got his darkest
movie yet with a villain more in common
with the jigsaw killer than jim carrey
bruce wayne goes to some bleak places in
the batman and these are his darkest
depths
by the time the batman starts it's been
two years since bruce wayne's mission to
fight crime in gotham has begun and by
his own admission he's failing things
have only gotten worse since he put on
the mask and began spending his night
striking fear into the hearts of
criminals even though the myth of the
batman and the looming threat of the
violence he spreads has rattled the
criminal element it has barely slowed
their pace bruce wants to change gotham
for the better but knows deep down that
what he is doing is not having its
intended effect before he can fix his
focus on the bigger picture and discover
the true breadth of corruption and graft
that has long strangled any potential
for improvement in gotham he must trudge
through this fruitless repetitive cycle
and by the time we meet him it's clear
that it's taking a toll
the first time we see batman in action
the audience gets a glimpse of what
these brutal late nights have been like
for bruce he encounters a gang of face
painted hoods recreationally assaulting
random people in the street and filming
it for kicks they're about to descend on
their latest victim a guy simply trying
to make it home on the train when they
are confronted by batman in full cloaked
regalia
i'm vengeance
on some level it's a thrilling action
scene on another it's a discomforting
example of bruce's flawed approach to
fixing a city he dispenses with the gang
members despite being outnumbered but
takes significant damage himself in the
process shot at tasered kicked punched
hit with weapons no amount of
billionaire armor and gadgetry is going
to fully soften those blows it's almost
like he has a masochistic streak
believing he deserves such nightly
beatdowns the ferocity it takes to
overcome those odds and fight the gang
showcases the sort of monster bruce has
become the innocent bystander he set out
to save from the face paint gang is far
from appreciative cowering under the
batman's gaze out of fear that he'll be
next the carnage on display makes it
hard for him to comprehend that bruce is
a good guy which makes you wonder what
exactly bruce wayne is getting out of
all of this
by virtue of being the only living soul
who knows bruce's secret alfred is
burdened with a sense of objectivity
that bruce is sorely lacking every night
bruce comes home to the cave and throws
himself into maintaining his case files
diaries and ongoing investigations it's
alfred the closest thing bruce has to a
father who has to perform the
unfortunate task of pointing out the
ineffective unsustainable nature of his
efforts but like many who love a person
with self-destructive tendencies he
still tries to be supportive much like
it was the case with christian bale's
batman it's bruce's responses and
reactions to real concerns that make
these early morning reality checks so
depressing
well you know how it is mr fox you're
out at night looking for kicks someone's
passing around the weaponized to loosen
the jets
we've already established through
bruce's own admission that he doesn't
really care if he dies doing what he's
doing but when alfred urges him to think
of his family's legacy as he continues
to ignore managing his fortune or
engaging with the company his father
left him bruce remarks that his mission
as the batman is his family's legacy
that alone would be a pretty dark
declaration to make but every time
alfred pushes him further bruce responds
with callous and selfish thoughts to put
alfred in his place when alfred tries to
be firm bruce reminds alfred he's his
butler and not his father when alfred
won't let bruce go to a funeral without
cufflinks on to keep up appearances he
makes bruce wear his own to which bruce
asks if alfred himself is a wayne it's a
question whose answer is meant to hurt
alfred for suggesting any connection to
this lineage alfred explains to bruce
that it was his thomas wayne who gifted
him the cufflinks and that he was close
enough to be family to the man bruce is
killing himself every night to avenge
the batman is a movie that more than any
other batman flick showcases bruce's
intelligence and skill as a detective
but this being a story that takes place
so early in his career it also
highlights how fallible he is midway
through unraveling the film's central
mystery behind who the riddler is and
what maze of moral rot he is trying to
uncover in gotham's history bruce and
lieutenant gordon believe they have
figured out who the rat is the latest
riddle they've solved references an
informant tethered to the riddler's
accusations that there's rampant
corruption both in the gotham city
police department and the city's
political power structure bruce believes
the riddle refers in broken spanish to a
rat with wings leading him to think it's
the penguin the right-hand man to mob
boss carmine falcone after an insane car
chase the batman and gordon tag team
penguin with their key accusation going
back and forth like a pair of cops in an
interrogation but penguin insists he's
not the rat when they repeat the riddle
which includes the phrase url rata
aladda penguin points out that it should
be la since the noun in question is
feminine bruce realizes the bit the
riddler emphasized is url and types the
rest of the phrase into a browser that
leads to a chat window with the riddler
there he realizes riddler's next victim
is bruce wayne and desperately tries to
race home to save alfred from the bomb
that's been shipped there but he arrives
too late alfred is hospitalized and in
critical condition all because bruce
misinterpreted a clue oh you're really
not as smart as i thought you were
as he probes more deeply into gotham's
history and sees how crooked its vaunted
power structures have long been he can
accept that the shape of his enemy is
more sprawling and vast than he
initially surmised but when the riddler
exposes the hidden history of bruce
wayne's own family it shakes him to his
foundation in this iteration of the
story the waynes were murdered not long
after thomas wayne's bid for mayor of
gotham the riddler posits that the
waynes and the other founding family of
the city the arkhams had always exerted
control over gotham through their power
and wealth but in no case was this more
pernicious than when a reporter was
digging into their past during the
campaign a journalist uncovered that
martha and arkham before she married
into the wanes suffered from severe
mental illness in her youth and had a
lengthy stay in the asylum of her
namesake thomas worried the scandal
would impact his campaign used his
influence over falcone having once saved
the man's life to get him to silence the
reporter who was murdered suddenly faced
with the realization that his father
wasn't the noble altruistic victim he
has committed himself to avenging bruce
is sent into a talespin calling into
question everything he's ever known
although he later discovers that what
he's been told by the riddler and
falcone isn't exactly the whole story
such revelations still rock him to the
very core of his being
when the riddler is revealed to be
forensic accountant edward nashton and
put behind bars batman comes face to
face with him only to discover some
disturbing wrinkles to their adversarial
relationship firstly bruce discovers
nashton knows who he really is he
arrives to their little teddy tet
thinking his days of anonymity are over
and that nashton is going to reveal his
identity but what he finds out is far
worse nashton goes on a lengthy rant
about how he always resented the
sympathy the city had for the poor
little rich boy who lost his parents but
not nashton or the other orphans
suffering in the dilapidated orphanage
whose funding had been pillaged by
greedy bureaucrats but beneath the
screed about his motivations is the
revelation that his master plan is even
larger than his string of killings
batman comes to understand that the
riddler views himself as a kindred
spirit the same kind of necessary
vigilante as batman he sees the two of
them together as partners as he's made
bruce an unwilling participant in his
plans later during a climactic showdown
with one of riddler's followers bruce
injects himself with some kind of
adrenaline shot it sends him into
overdrive he brutally beats his opponent
nearly killing him the man near death
responds to the question who are you
with a haunting answer instead of being
straightforward batman's enemy says i'm
vengeance echoing batman's very own
words right back at him as rock bottom
as this moment might be for bruce it's a
necessary wake-up call for as dark as
the batman is it's a story that must
plumb those depths to come out the other
side transformed a bruce wayne who
understands that gotham needs more than
fear and violence to be saved from
itself it needs hope and so does bruce
wayne
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
you